hey i'm kaylee bryant and i play josie
saltzman on the cw's legacies
hey guys i'm nora dominic from buzzfeed
celeb and also the tv editor for
buzzfeed
as we all know legacies is a spin-off
from the vampire diaries so as a super
fan of
all of the shows i'm challenging kaylee
today to compete against
me in a vampire diaries universe quiz
kaylee are you excited are you ready i'm
so nervous but i'm ready
here's how it'll work we'll take turns
answering the multiple choice questions
that neither of us have seen before
each question we get correct is worth
one point if either of us gets the
question wrong
the other person will have a chance to
answer correctly and steal the point
there's a bonus question at the end of
the quiz where we can wager any of the
points we earned whoever has the most
points at the end of the quiz
wins i've been watching the vampire
diaries since i was a
freshman in high school so i'm really
excited to be here wait were you a fan
before you got cast on legacies oh yeah
a huge fan like you i started watching
it when i was 15 and like binge watched
the whole
thing everybody was like oh kaylee's the
fact checker of legacies kaylee's a fact
checker
and now i feel like i'm about to get
dethroned and that's okay
i accept my faith we're in the middle of
shooting a very complicated episode
right now
and my brain is so frazzled i'm like
rooting for you
no i'm rooting for you
which salvatore brother met elena first
and how
damon she visited the salvatore boarding
house stephen he bumped into elena at
school
damon who ran into elena the night her
parents died and mistook her for
catherine
stefan he saved elena from drowning is
so easy it's damon
in season 3 episode 17 we learned that
damon actually met elena first on the
night her parents died
while she was calling her parents to
pick her up from a party
damon saw her and this took her for
catherine they talked briefly
and then damon compelled her to forget
about the whole interaction
that's such an easy one though it's all
going to go downhill from here
what is hope michelson's middle name and
why
eliza to honor her uncle elijah caroline
because
klaus fell in love with her the moment
he laid eyes on her
mystic because her parents wanted to
honor the town they met
mystic falls on dre ev because it was
her mother's birth name
it's d andrea in the originals we
learned that haley's birth name was
andrea lavenere
so hope's middle name is to honor her
mother's werewolf pack
and i only now think of jenny who plays
lizzie
saying hope andrea michaelson in the
legacies every time i think about this
i only hear jenny boyd's like pope
andrea michaelson
stefan is a vampire who is particularly
vicious with his human victims
a vampire otherwise known as blink
an original a ripper a heretic or a
hybrid
this is very easy it's b a ripper yeah
this is basic knowledge
klaus is a hybrid or a combination of
two supernatural beings
which combo is he a vampire and werewolf
b vampire and witch c witch and werewolf
d vampire and doppelganger it is
a hundred percent vampire and werewolf
class is a hybrid aka a vampire and a
werewolf i was a huge fan of the
originals and class is one of my
favorite characters so
that one's an easy one each michaelson
created their own bloodline of vampires
which vampire was
not from klaus's line this is where it's
going to get difficult
okay this is complicated catherine
pierce cammy o'connell
marcel gerard damon salvatore tyler
lockwood
[Music]
oh tyler lockwood right no
okay so i think it's cammy o'connell
because if i'm remembering correctly
klaus
loved cammy and i don't think he turned
her so i'm gonna go with cammy
there it is cammy was turned by aurora
who is actually from rebecca's bloodline
see that's where it got me because i was
like oh yeah he loved candy so like why
wouldn't there be the connection there i
forgot that tyler turned into a vampire
oh yeah me too i always think of him as
the first werewolf and that's
basically where it ends see this is
where it all goes downhill what year
did damon and stephen salvatore become
vampires
1862 1863
1864 or 1865.
now here's my problem i'm really bad at
math so there's no way i can figure this
out so it's just gonna have to be a
guess
i'm gonna go with 1863
which is wrong should i steal i'm gonna
go with an
i'm gonna go with sixty-five
64 right in the middle so it says damon
and stefan became vampires in 1864 which
means
they would be about 182 and 174 years
old
today oh very old so nia risk get a
point on that question
yeah that was really hard which of these
monsters has never appeared on legacies
gargoyle siren sphinx necromancer
krampus lady of the lake this one's easy
we've never had a siren on the show yeah
siren was just vampire i know my own
show you did it the legacy super squad
has fought
many monsters including the necromancer
krampus lady of the lake gargoyles and
the sphinx
however sirens have only appeared on the
vampire diaries
i'm so proud of you what food is josie
salsman allergic to
strawberries shellfish peanuts
avocado carrots or seaweed
oh god if i get this wrong you're gonna
be so
mad at me okay hold on was it when you
and landon went on that date
yeah okay okay okay it's not
strawberries it's not peanuts
you were eating something at the grill i
don't think it was avocados or carrots
it's gotta be shelf as your seaweed and
i feel like it's gonna be something
a little more random than shellfish
because i don't remember it
so i think i'm gonna go with seaweed yay
good job
there josie is actually allergic to
seaweed and we find that out during
legacy season two episode two
when she goes on a not so great sushi
date with landon your other dates have
been so much better
i was very bitter about josie being
allergic to seaweed because seaweed is
one of my favorite snacks and so i
texted right i was like you know that
you're doing this on purpose
what were you eating with the seaweed
was it we went to sushi
yeah we went to get sushi which song
played when damon elena kissed for the
first time
what the water gave me by florence the
machine gravity by sara bareilles
chasing cars by snow patrol
never let me go by florence the machine
oh no
oh god you know this one i don't yeah
you do
it's definitely by florence the machine
i'm going to say never let me go by
floor into the machine
on season three episode 19 of the
vampire diaries damon helena's first
kiss
is underscored by florence the machines
never let me go like i knew yeah i was
like haley you can't mess this one up
that's like the big moment outside the
motel it's iconic yeah
courtney and i courtney bandico who
plays finch we were talking about like
iconic moments
she said that stefan and caroline's
first kiss was iconic i was like no no
no
no no no no no damon and elena proved me
wrong
well and now josie and finch had their
big moment with the
sparks and everything see now you're
adding to the list what is kai parker's
twitter handle
oh at king kai
1974 at cobra kai 1973
at king kai 1983 and at cobra kai 1972
oh god okay i definitely followed this
twitter account when it was you know
first revealed it's one of the cobra
kai's i know that
i think it's cobra kai 1972.
yeah so on season six episode nine of
the vampire diaries kai officially makes
a twitter account with the handle
cover kai 1972 you know like karate kid
one of my favorite characters wait and
then you've gotta do scenes with them
which must have been amazing oh my god
amazing and
he's the sweetest human being on the
planet which is confusing but he's
lovely
all right so now we've got a bonus
question that neither of us have
seen yet and now we have to wage your
points before we can answer it are you
ready
so how difficult do we think this
question is yeah like a sliding scale
like one to ten
i'm going with it's gonna be like a ten
here's the thing i'm already
losing this could tip you it could i'm
gonna do it i'm gonna say four points
okay i'm doing the four i'm doing the
four four points each what kind of
really
are the seven salvatore drive
i know the color i've been in damon's
car
around gaiman's car i can't tell you
what make it is okay i just have to
guess
everybody that watches this video is
going to be like wow kali and nora don't
know the cars
they're going to be screaming at their
kids like how could you not know
okay i did red corvette and then i said
1960. okay i know it's little and we're
red
the year is i want to say based off of
the body of the vehicle
it's in the 50s 56 oh great year
and i'm gonna say it's a poor shop 1963
porsche 356b
carmen coop red oh it's a carmen and
that makes so much sense
i'm never gonna forget it now if we had
gotten together
as one we would have equaled each other
out to get the perfect answer
kaylee zero nora won
well it was a pleasure this was so much
fun yes
thank you guys so much for watching you
can tune into legacies on the cw app or
on netflix and you can also play the
same quiz that we've been taking
in the description box down below
you